what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are here today to watch
cobra kai season 5 episode 3 today if
you didn't catch our reactions episode
102 they're up here on the channel
already we're kind of just binging this
right now so guys leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated strike that
subscribe button so you can get notified
when our reaction for the next episode
of cobra kai is up here on the channel
as always full interaction watch alongs
where you sync up with a time code uh
meaning your own copy over for our super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
cover a bunch of shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included of course team at
prepper thank you guys for helping down
these highlights andrew how you doing
i'm doing how are you i'm doing too john
doing yep andrew grassy shirts gotta
mention that every video let's do this
[Music]
he said he never played before
beginner
yeah right i know when i've been hustled
you insult my honor
it's a reference to part two he's been
kicking a lot of ass lately first
round's on me fellas nicki and anusha
back louie's stupid how'd you hit him oh
[ __ ] i believe you two have met
sensei taguchi
you might have some old friends to call
upon
but not as many as me
like bards this is my backyard
i'm not the one who needs to go
you're playing with fire danny boy
and i am cassody
[Laughter]
bought a big boom
served
this is so sweet
mexico changed you
you should see my van
should be illegal to deface someone
else's property like that it is
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah i think i need to make an apology
meal for him too
oh
she pregnant
put some of those dragon peppers in it
what'd you do tweak yourself on the back
nine no counting guest room not good you
know i'm sorry about that we used to
have a bed in there but it pretty much
got destroyed when cobra kai broke into
our house do not worry i will not allow
them to attack home again you can afford
another bad day so you can absolutely
afford it
only owns a car dealership
we call old friend first
do you know any old friend of silva
oh he would contact contact him
you just bought yourself a champion
hey
you
[Applause]
[Music]
never heard him say the airport there's
the adult scene so many f4s this season
most of them were in spanish so it
doesn't count
i think i might be pregnant
how we use protection it's not 100 these
things can happen
okay
who uses protection these days
i haven't even taken a test yet right
the test
all right let's pee on a stick i mean
you'd be on a stick
i'm fine yeah me too 100
i'll pull the van around okay
i'm going to mexico
gotta get out of here
remember how he freaked out when robbie
was born
is this him she finally takes back
yeah says she wants to uh talk tonight
what did she say exactly
we should talk tonight
we should talk his code for
i i want to break up what it is
not necessarily
moon is really big on communication
maybe sam does just actually want to
talk
can't wait to see you tonight um
how are you that's good yeah right
desperate
look cute
he knows he's in deep [ __ ]
i feel like things have been off lately
there's so much i want to say maybe i
should just
lay it all out nope
no less is more i'm with yaz it's better
to have these conversations in person i
like oh yasmin and dimitri are now
though texters
i'm okay
should i add a smiley face or something
no really
[Music]
devon an angel right there on your
shoulder
dude that's bad there's not even an
emoji yeah
[Laughter]
it's emotional karate
there he is
like wow
yes he looks great
he does not look so bad to me
yeah well that guy tried to kill me once
either forget or forgive something like
that who did i
[Laughter]
i bet he's a sweetheart he runs at
animal rescue
what's he got there some sort of hansel
good for cutting pipe
that one good for cutting bone
looks like he's got some goons working
for him
he's safe for me
no i don't want you getting in any more
fights
he's running a red room on the dark web
it's just when shannon was pregnant with
robby i wasn't ready i felt useless
i don't want to be that guy again i
understand miguel was a surprise too and
i was scared but
now we have each other
right
right
can learn together
[Music]
ever since the tournament you've been
off balance
it's clear there's been some tension
with miguel
the only thing you're gonna find in this
pot as yourself it's not so scary
right
piggyback that pizza dough freezer be so
cool do one of those i would love to do
one of those
how about a nice pair of earrings
how much is that
the octopus oh
actually it's been reduced
reduced
great how much
after tax 182
that's it
do you maybe have one with fewer
tentacles
[Laughter]
that's a good price damn yeah
miguel could earn that by the time i'm
finished with them they're gonna be
unrecognizable
and you know i think i know exactly how
to do it i think
i'm gonna start
by cutting off their legs
oh yeah yeah those kids are in for a big
surprise no listen to me you suck of a
[ __ ] i'm not gonna have you or your
ponytail pin play one finger on any of
our kids
daniel russo he got that right [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you work in a furniture store
daniel i own the furniture store
saw the licks off
[Music]
there is a lot of work to do before your
little blessing arrives
let's get to it
watch how to dab
here
practice it with beers
like this gently
[Music]
just like that
oh [ __ ]
you'll be ready when the real one
arrives
what a little miracle needs a healthy
organic diet do the egg baby or a sack
of flour johnny
eighth grade make sure your space is
baby friendly
[Music]
you need to look in every nook and
cranny for things like mold pests and
other hazards
oh my god jesus
[Laughter]
that's fine johnny's breathed worse you
know after the old valley tournament my
life was ruined i mean i was lost so i
found myself working odd jobs and one
day i'm moving furniture and i meet my
future father-in-law he showed me that i
could do something with these hands
other than fight can move stuff
and saw things
oh my god it's gonna become like altered
states
i love it
i'm supposed to be figuring out who i am
what do you mean larusso 2.0
sam you're one of the girls
you're the girl who broke my heart
[Music]
my girlfriend sam
why can't you just be supportive they're
gonna start dripping blood yeah
quick flashes of satanic imagery
i know exactly who you are
princess
tori
dark side sam
trippy wicked
[Music]
oh my gosh i had the most incredible
vision
is there anything you could tell me that
might bring this guy down i need
something i haven't even seen him in
years
i i just don't know what i could do to
help oh my god he's working with him
please
say it ain't so
that's exactly what i don't want right
now
oh
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what is happening
maybe chosen's right it's kind of crazy
we're watching these two fight each
other
[Music]
chosen he didn't attack me he's on the
same side wait if this guy's with you
what the hell daniel this is just a
giant misunderstanding if this is
misunderstanding you better call
ambulance
oh christ
what
it's a word on chosen's bad side that's
hilarious i love it
that's so funny
i think sam and i are having some issues
and
honestly i'm not even sure what i'm
supposed to say
about the truth
he made you sign a contract i made them
put it in writing
i did promise to be 50 of cobra kai you
tell me you still have it
daniel no way i mean
i see you liking that tufted blue suede
better than the couch he's sleeping on
regard to a former client of yours terry
silver this is very urgent please give
me a call back asap when you get this
message thank you
i wouldn't name the guy on the voicemail
they're loading the couch after he beat
their ass get blood on the couch don't
get blood on the couch
those poor guys are just working a hard
day man
they got beat up and went back to work
look sam i have an apology
you don't need to explain
i really respect you for taking the time
that you needed to find yourself
oh
but
i need that time too
i need a little break
to figure out who i am outside of all
that
you say break what do you
what do you mean he's on and off again
[ __ ] man we were unable
i want what's best for you always you
know then
that's hard
look it doesn't mean that we can't be
friends right
[Music]
of course
you're a nice guy miguel call me
whenever okay
yeah
okay
[Music]
this poor kid oh man that that is not a
fun walk
oh
i ended up buying it too
oh
just go on a sleeping spree miguel
this morning i didn't think i could be
one of those lame dads with the baby
carrier and the diapers and all that
crap
but if it means i'm doing it with you
do whatever it takes
we're having a
[Laughter]
my
baby
[Music]
hi i'm calling in regard to a former
client of yours terry silver this is
very urgent please give me a call back
asap when you get this message thank you
nice
you and i are gonna be seeing a lot more
of each other
first i'm gonna deal with my old friend
and then i'll deal with you
oh man he took his shirt off and
everything
real powerful for that moment
he put it right back on when he's got it
oh no he burned his business [ __ ]
oh what
that is awful
oh wow
i mean
you gotta come
finally the scales are balanced
god
wow
all right i had to take it away take it
away earn uh that was a very interesting
episode i really enjoyed it uh i think
the thing that's
uh really drawing my interest uh most
which i wasn't expecting is samantha's
journey i really like the the whole
identity crisis it's very compelling to
me uh just finding out who she is and
what she's going through just through
all the seasons what she's been through
and it's like i said it's very
compelling it's interesting and she's a
very good actress she's got very good
range and i'm glad that's on display
here and again seeing her relationship
with miguel uh you know with what what
happened in season four and then what
it's come to here just it was very sad
and dramatic with what uh what just
occurred so i was really uh
like i said i was very emotional and i
loved both those actors they have such
good on on-screen chemistry they're so
good together uh i love
love that we got uh the actor sean kane
in back who plays mike barnes that's
awesome uh i i mean everyone knows i'm a
huge fan of karate kid part three even
though i always consider that the
weakest part of the the trilogy of the
miyagi verse but
i love seeing that guy back again him
and uh seeing him and daniel in her hack
together was great seeing that he has a
furniture store was not what i was
expecting to see but that was cool to
see um but yeah he's got a really good
on-screen presence and i love seeing him
back again and i mean yeah you just
don't uh don't mess with terry silver is
the uh message i got from this episode
and thomas ian griffith even though the
limited that's why he's such a good
actor the limited screen time you always
feel his presence there and he's just
fantastic and i'm just really interested
and fascinated to see what else happens
throughout the rest of the season and
really quickly we'll get to the easter
eggs at the beginning of the episode we
saw that i chosen said you insult my
intelligence to daniel's cousins he said
that to daniel in part two he said you
insult my intelligence again and i'll
kill you after daniel messed up his
little scam that he was doing uh then we
got uh mike barnes saying i want fifty
percent that was a reference to karate
kid part three where he won fifty
percent of the dojos from terry silver
uh we also got the uh octopus necklace
that was obviously a reference to season
one with uh they bought they got the
stuffed toy from golf and stuff which is
in ventura county they got the octopus
uh so yeah
probably missing some other ones but
those are the ones that came to mind
that's impressive yeah buddy decent you
know you're currently kids yeah
john
why don't you go second today
i'm like i don't know what you're doing
playing games yeah
terry silver
tennis happening right here
yeah what are you gonna do you got an
opinion you got opinion ready to go i
can go
no i gotta be like yeah i would like to
hear your thoughts um
i
i think
the heart of this show is so strong
and
it's such a sweet tender show every sing
every time we check back in with cobra
timer
because i was talking with someone the
other day before this came out
who hadn't watched cobra count i was
trying to like
i hadn't revisited a cobra cut i was
trying to tell them
why cobra kai is so great and i just i
felt like anything i was saying just
wasn't enough
because it's so hard to like summarize
it
and because it's like this show i was
like no you gotta understand it's life
guys life as i'm sort of saying that
over and over i'm like i feel like my
point's not getting communicated
and like you get an episode like this
with the pregnant with the whole thing
with being pregnant and facing the fears
of becoming a father and then
the themes of having to better yourself
like there's so much nurturing
with these with these characters you
really care about who go through such
difficult experiences and wanting to do
their best at the same time and like
there's so many different storylines
happening here and they're all so
enjoyable in their own ways
like samantha having to confront herself
and doing some experiment like it's not
an experiment like we've seen crazier
[ __ ] than that obviously experiment but
for for a karate kid that's freaking
that's random like we've never seen
something like that you're diving into
the subconscious of the mind and having
to confront your inner demons and the
things that you ever were haunted by
that you haven't overcome
coming face to face with yourself that
oh my god it's not tori it's myself that
i'm i'm battling really she's just a
representation of something deeper
within me
and i liked her i liked what she was
telling miguel why they couldn't be
together and then knowing that miguel's
like experiencing this hurt and anger
underneath it all i mean especially with
the freaking merry-go-round him and
samantha had been on this whole time but
you know she does have to work on
herself it's a very everyone in l.a
that's what they're all doing everyone
in l.a is just always working on
themselves very valuable very valued and
you alone it's a very valley valley
thing to say very value to work on
yourself and very valid to run a
furniture store no it's not it is more
universal than that um so yeah i think
uh and man i you know
zolo mart monic maniquin or
just say blue
nailed it
whatever his name is
like i said last last episode what he's
doing here i'm like yeah you're bringing
it back to her he's like the star of the
show he's so good he's so freaking good
and
i i feel like his acting is better than
ever and also
you know bringing back mike barnes
reminded me of
what this show is also done so well
which is if you watch those like
original karate kid movies i'm about to
say something that might upset some
people if you watch those original
karate kid movies they're very you know
there's a lot of cheese in there
especially with the acting
obviously like terry silver
he was on cocaine
hamminess
even chosen to a certain extent then
johnny lawrence not i don't i don't
recall him being that cheesy but you
bring them back into the show and then
you're like man
were they always this good they're
always as good of actors they're all
they're all like great actors but that
that level of of talent just wasn't as
felt in those original experiences for
me with a lot of these characters like
outside of ralph macchio
so you bring him here and you're like oh
he's great he's fantastic and even this
show does such a good job making he goes
like is he is all a big part of terry
silver's plug is he is he's just messing
with him did he really follow the good
path to terry silver already getting
contact with him it's uh it's strong
strong suitable [ __ ] man so
yeah i think everything they're doing
here is is great and uh i don't know i
thought the chosen like early in the
first episode with the chosen with the
size
i thought okay so is this going to be
the reoccurring joke yeah that that
there's a
there's a cultural language barrier
yeah no he's kidding and he's always
gonna have random weapons to make this
correct
become violent yeah i actually thought
what they did here was
was really funny yeah when he beat up
everyone like you didn't see it
went ahead and did it yeah
well there's something there i was this
episode easily had the wildest
oscillation of tones and that
bordered and it didn't cross the line
for me but it did border on getting like
a little too big and a little too wacky
because i kept being like man at any
point mike could just snap and be like
i'm suing both yeah but yeah there's
something like the way they drew that
mystery where we
i think they're really good at giving
you just enough to know that yeah okay
if you're really paying attention
you can kind of tell that the
perspective we're in with danny and
chosen is not correct but
they still manage to ring all the fun
and all of the sort of well maybe they
are right you know like there's enough
sort of peripheral mystery to drive that
tension but also drive the fun and i
feel like another thing this show is is
really good at doing aside from really
honing it on the heart and really kind
of honoring everything that came before
it is also just
recognizing how
the the range of tonality that the
original karate kid movies had because
there is a lot of heart but karate kid 3
has like cocaine sprinkled all over it
and i thought they brought some of that
coked out quality to this but in a way
that felt appropriate and that gives you
these exciting left turns where yet now
we are on a vision quest in a
whatever they call the pods now instead
of sensory deprivation and and and two
yeah like you said it is life it's like
you could swap karate out especially in
sam's story for any number of other
things that overtake your life in high
school and sort of co-opt your identity
and and two seeing the kind of
intersection she's at that we're all at
in our own lives with different people
of
this is what you are to me you're the
person who broke my heart you're my
protege who has to live up to me like
there's so many great
threads
and they to me never feel too ham-fisted
or too like i get it you didn't need to
put it in the dialogue you know and this
season two seems like the most mature
because the it doesn't feel uh bogged
down by being like well we have to do
dojo stuff we have to do you know see
every character of the ensemble in every
episode it feels more
natural while it also seems to be taking
more swings in terms of tone and trying
out fun things and yeah giving the
characters like real life to deal with
so i also love too where they showed
that scene with johnny and miguel where
johnny's giving him the advice about
samantha
i think because johnny you guys
mentioned you know the heart of the
episode and also johnny just like
you know changing himself to be a good
father but johnny i think johnny
realized like he's already be he is a
good father to miguel you know the the
way he uh his interactions with miguel
how he's been just guiding him the last
well i mean i know the show is more like
we're in season five but it's been only
a couple years in the
in the uh in the shows universe but
he's he's been a father to mcgill you
know he's been that that mentor so i
mean
i i love that realization by giant like
hey i actually i am ready for this i am
a good father you know miguel is he's
basically my son so that was i thought
that was a great scene uh one last thing
i don't know if i would call this a
easter egg a reference but when uh she
was in that deprivation thing or
whatever and she saw yasmin and moon in
the laker uh girl jerseys that was from
season one episode three i think it was
called esque ito i think the episode was
coming together
there you go
yeah i just rewatched the show twice so
uh they were wearing the laker girl uh
jerseys for the the halloween dance so
yeah wow one and did anybody notice i
feel like when she's squaring off
against herself in the head-on shots
it's the actress who plays sam but in
the profile shots it looked like it
actually was the actress who played tori
in the that would be interesting we have
to well when i would rewatch that i'm
going to look for that it seemed like an
interesting visual language yeah i was
getting some double impact you know john
john claude van damme vibes there where
he's fighting fighting his twin but yeah
it's me
yeah
you're like what
1991 sheldon latish i know you did not
but i still wanted to say it
yes
watch that movie double impact
he's fought a lot of twins
sean claude van damme
top 10
duplicates of himself
he's
twins
it at least three times
i think there's one movie called
replicas a replicant
it was like straight to dvd ah
i must have i could read your mind
replicas i don't remember anyway
all right guys thanks for being here
we're gonna watch the next one picture
of the day shout out
pandemic jones what's his real name john
paul pj paul well we have looked up paul
on urbandictionary.com
check this out
this term is usually used for guys that
mean a lot to you pandemic jones that's
perfect does mean a lot to me
i think about them way too often to the
point where it gets perverted
this guy particularly is a keeper oh
yeah absolutely yeah
yeah oh man yeah i just keep in there
and i throw away the key
and feed him food through a little small
sliding square door
he has amazing features
yes he does
he has a six-pack but only on one side
of his body an amazing
voice
very high pitched but very deep at the
same time make you cry i've never heard
such a thing shatter a mirror it hurts
but it's soothing
and good absolutely loving personality
so true both republican and democrat the
best of both worlds well-rounded he
knows how to make you smile just by
saying a few
words
the other day
paul messaged us and was like hey
all of a sudden
i just smiled till i started to bleed
from my cheeks
the reconstructive surgery to get my
face back to what it is now
was worth it oh just to hear from you
the constant level of pain we both exist
in you know resisting the urge to smile
because of you is is a sacrifice that we
are happy to make and sometimes this
term is also used for guys with big
private areas oh yeah that's a given oh
dude the biggest private area oh
definitely all
private areas put everyone to shame
simultaneously massive
and also
cylinder it's a perfect
cylinder
i've never seen anything quite like
geometrically perfect yeah it fits per
like
if a kid will be playing with blocks
they would get confused yes
yeah no totally don't don't don't whip
it out when you're playing with blocks
in front of children
yes they can learn energy
they yeah they'll they'll have something
to aspire to
thanks thanks love you buddy
[Music]